so many of you know I just want to
welcome first of all all our age and
colleagues and I want to express my
deepest sympathy to all the Haitians who
are in the room tonight but also all
those were 80 the tragedy which has hit
their country is a limited imaginable as
you probably saw on two pictures I was
in Haiti with a team of systems and we
were there during the earthquake in a
few days after that and I just can help
describe two miserable planet that we
have seen the tragedy as you know has
brought massive loss of lives of the
part of the Haitians feeling isolated
vocals many don't have water food or
shelter at this stage we have lost so
soon a lot about you one colonies it's
probably the biggest loss that anyone
has ever seen and therefore we are in
front of this tragedy that we don't
understand and which is hitting IDT in a
way that is quite an understandable I
want to tell you that we went to ADT
last year sefa and six students because
we want it to look at this country
each other with a six 2004 seen a food
crisis and rest and a change of the
Prime Minister when a government which
had difficulties for five weeks then saw
hurricanes son knows the financial
crisis and now an earthquake and this is
the space Aleutian years and if you
remember that her et was already fragile
states before the earthquake that
sixty-five percent as a matter of fact
more than seventeen seventy percent of
the time last year was 80 of the people
live with less co2 during the day and in
a state of extreme poverty if you
realize that at that time before ye
earthquake institutions in need to
distract them the government will need a
lot of capacity movie you will
understand why this is a crisis of
extraordinary proportion with a lot of
challenges ahead of us however in spite
of all these problems that Haiti out and
count
sounds as I seem to have been a quiet
here and I remember calling hadiyyah-lah
the vendor participation also to frosty
subtle to wish him a happy in here a
little did I know that you've done but
I've another he saying people for the
first time hi to people are getting
together families are inviting each
other there is a semblance of peace they
are alliances in 40 past and things are
starting slowly to recover it was a
window of opportunity with the
conference in Washington just a
recipient who have been a 14-2
especially border of the century journal
and we keep trying to bring the private
sector in haiti and we're doing a
research project on the relationship
between the private sector and develop
an epistle and wonder how a bee sting
operation which did have a develop
advantage in a junction eighty percent
of extreme poverty could really
establish peace and we realized quickly
that the higher security which reduced
our carbonation could not be sustained
if it could not be trusted in
socio-economic
people and learn where we were when the
earthquake as you know there was a
conference in hospital today there will
be also a meeting in Davos very simple
imitating we present a long-term
proposal probably with a private sector
as well and we are here looking at these
extraordinary tragedy and all wondering
how I antes need to go back to his feet
and I would like to say that for my
experience I don't think anybody can
rebuild Haiti I think only the relation
Stan and I think we should never forget
this and we should keep the patient
opportunity to do that with dignity will
there be able to restore credibility and
activity of your state to be the odeon
systems which are over capacity which
are but we have
define their needs and tell us the wind
chime health this reinforces that we are
to tie them into the wrong with you to
be deal and i'm not talking about living
with cement and dolls and water that me
be the way they provided the leadership
community really needs the font i'm
talking about whether we building
society and i'm talking about a charge
to need to national community which is
not valid short only and that is the
challenge that we all face in front of
fragile state it takes a long time this
will be a long haul and my question will
be to the speaker with the international
community's staying cause say the time
it will take to tell 280 be a naturally
them to discuss all things i would like
to introduce to light our speakers I'm
so grateful that you
that option is there to the bone and
couldn't sell it body DPT lips to our as
a lighter side who's anybody but we have
a job you know who works at the helm of
this type in operation for eight years
and who is teaching about for java state
that seeker who will unsure tell us what
is happening optimistic inside let me
introduce all these people to our very
first to introduce to you our patient
Carly jos-na Mahalo an autonomy of the
sex relationship of the Clinton and the
Washington conference the government of
high
inhibition to try to define it needs and
give the information to Bill Clinton of
us to what they needed and what he
should therefore us the private sector
and let's leave out there in Haiti was
severly working very hard on this and
Justin michela was his advisor healing
George and also in Haiti I knew they
were you find their priorities before
the earthquake no doubt they will work
and we need to review and two we tie all
these priorities now and I know that
justly would very much like to subscribe
to help in an internship to help him do
research on how to build the capacity of
the state after the disaster of that
magnitude so if you are interested
please come to see me I'll be circulated
be coming over terms of reference and I
just want to tell you that this is
exciting
envelope Giovanni that we speak French
or Creole which is even better I just
want to go to a leg next speaker you
know I office of the secretary channel
diversity policy planning things with
many issues including the food crises
health global health and also
counterterrorism he will explain to us
the position of the UN ambassador Martin
is from the diverse nation and in theni
media consultant all the way on economic
issues he is not even offer for long but
this will be baptism of fire and he has
brought his versatility in UNHCR with
the refugees and we better than 10 min
giv total chaplain and he has dealt with
many conflicts being gosh
oh man falsely in his work so he has a
great experience and we'd also like to
bring by orange emphasize needs no
introduction as the director the eris
institute and he will probably be one of
the first tickets because he has to
travel there has to be early and we want
to thank him he has been trotting around
the globe and I know exactly how it
feels that channel where is that him
that is Tatyana woman was it is from
Haiti she was in into the dark matter of
fact we met an interview her she has
she's a Haitian voice she was a
tremendous amount about hotels really
she works Jeffrey Sachs indios Institute
and I'm sure the manager
speaker last but not least is Luis para
Louise who is from you I DP from the
recovery section he has worked on so
many conflicts including the tsunami in
community level and he has a great
experience on emergency as well as
transition phases from the oceans didn't
mean to be covering I just want to ask
him to welcome the power
what what they see anybody else astra
event to have a country
my name is people who says John McCallum
I'm senior advisor to be nice fellow
award to the United Nations ambassador
that people there I fully subscribe to
the notion that was expressed earlier by
our hosts that annotations should own
the process of rebuilding the country
patients should drive the process or
rebuilding the country patient will need
for the help that they can get from
from you citizens of the world what that
nation should be in the forefront of
every other country and not on this
video its infrastructure but it really
build is its political and social
structure in a way that provides more
equity to the people of the country and
that ensure that those people
bad more responsible more efficient at
running things in the country from those
are the aims and discerns under which
how we should focus and operator now let
me say a little bit more about the
author that I was doing as an inland
empire I said the office was set up and
respond to the initiative taken by the
you
dental to a point especially overheating
in order to steal more interest in a
year perhaps in a more capital
investment
via the good offices are pregnant
attention we work from the very
beginning with with with the president
to try to trigger more interest in here
in fact two days before the meeting was
up before they are pretty lady we were
my educated about their eyes were in the
midst of trying to me which was gone to
teach her the prevalence of a in New
York where many interested investors in
the country as well as people were going
to take a look at how to do are
insertable issues of disaster risk and
disasters that a country face but as you
probably know from it part of the reason
why the international community
responded and begin to respond in a much
more focused fashion to a was back in
the ink in 2008 the fall 2008 for
tropical storms in the country and
produce severe damage to the ultimate
evaluate to determine when I
another dallas flooding the found
ensuring by causing what would this
major that a bit about a billion dollars
in damage the risk of 80 facing under
such natural catastrophe because the
infrastructure of the country has been
weakened over over time and some of the
causes of a very one that I'm not gonna
into them the risk of the country facing
is natural catastrophes is greater than
ever and as the first put demonstrated
because because there were steps that
needs to be taken there were nothing in
order to build out a structure that
would respond and to take into account
the amount of change and natural changes
because subsets are nothing big and then
we have a situation in which that led to
the death of thousands of people the
disruption of about three million people
at the very least at this eternity
countries sliders they disrupted and
therefore it puts squarely before us
that need to think in terms of
rebuilding the country rebuilding it
better not just squat on it but the
entire country and rebuilding in that
state how is that going to proceed one
greater in the town first but let's not
underestimate what has happened
the governor most of the buildings that
serve as institutions from which
government officials work has been
destroyed the only only
building that in my mind
so spending is the office of the Prime
Minister have put that office and in
turn to a homeless camp and prominences
is not instantly using that office to
operate out of it but as you probably
read newspapers president Prime Minister
operate out of makeshift headquarters
basically for the press what that means
specifically the power communications
within various Asian Hamid offices in
severely disrupted the acidity a
significant obstacles to two leaders
communicating to the staff to other
people what is going on the country and
what the steps are that the government
stating there are certainly
communication problem between 80 for the
friends and the people work for the
government after the photographs but at
the same time our challenge is to be
able to manage exactly
the amount of the world was translating
to promises of international assistance
for Madame Internet
sistance underground is also for so you
have so what happened fiction I'm trying
to go for your lesson so we can push the
discussion pretty I'm trying to draw
four years one in which very very very
easily you had a weak government which
has been rendered much weaker but from
whom much is expected while so right now
I would stay for about what they are
international relief groups that honor
that have far more resources to bring to
bear to the situation than the
government can and and that that's a
challenge that we can have to face now
today as we speak has been
international conference on a TV hello
Montreal to the Bremen a conference that
will set the stage for me sometimes
perhaps not sure exactly when to be the
minion cambio but that meeting is gone
to focus on what does it go departed on
him I true that my colleague upon what
you say about some of some of those of
feeling given that their involvement
days inn in different version of England
as well as as their connection to the
actual media we are going to we are
fizzing out the rescue engine
transmission today we are with our in a
pack and Facebook and success of any the
creature is going to be for to be really
based on what happens with it
back six groups and what r that is a
strategy that is winning strategy that
takes into account pepper that need to
be made over the next 10 20 thank you
thank you very much Lisbon and thanks to
all the fellow panelists everybody's
doing heroic things and added two
solutions let me take a couple of parts
of this very complicated mega-disaster
of course we're facing one of the
deadliest natural disasters in human
history recently scrutiny a few worth
waiting death tolls ever reported it
still continues to rise what jocelyn
said just now about the different
overlapping the phases of response is
very important the rescue search rescue
period is basically over there is an
urgent relief period right now to keep
the population alive water food shelter
and so forth that will continue of
course for for some months and there's
very urgent issues involved for example
the beginning of the rainy season and
beginning of the hurricane season coming
shortly so very profound to the
difficult challenges of Teknique people
from risks that are just around the
corner but all of this is going to
happen integrated not only with
reconstruction that's obvious but also
with development because the problem is
not to reconstruct Haiti the problem is
that Haiti was already impoverished
without was the most basic
infrastructure without the safety of
lodgings reinforce structures which
obviously contributed to this horrific
death toll so many things are
intertwined in the process and we
holistic view which is not easy in and
of itself and for which the
international organizations are going to
be very severely challenged then because
solid specialized in relief some are
thinking in terms of the peace provision
and food with water right now but we're
talking about something that goes far
beyond setting up tents or far beyond
the issue of bringing in food aid and
emergency relief as important as that is
so let me talk a little bit about the
these different different elements my
focus is on the public sector want to
stress because the private sector will
have its role in a while but the private
sector does not have its leadership role
right now and in general even before
this earthquake there was not a proper
balance between the public investments
needed at the private investments needed
because the private sector oh
lives on an adequate infrastructure and
there did not exist an adequate
infrastructure before so chasing
business investment whether it's no
power inadequate groans and so forth
can't work anyway this must be a public
led effort for a while nan de private
firms on contract won't do things but
it's going to be public financing and
public leadership to get something going
again now there's some very urgent
issues I'm not an expert you're honest
but tech cities and so forth are very
dangerous in a hurricane alley and what
is the proper strategy even over weeks
therefore for where people are going to
live great start and when the hurricane
season begins because they won't be in
harm's way if this is handled in a
normal quote unquote normal refugee or
displaced persons context flooding
massive storms massive hurricanes this
is what this country lives through and
it has to be has to be
they need to account of course regard to
seeing aftershocks and her dis afternoon
for our psychologists about further
trigger earthquakes we also heard about
the possibilities reinforced building's
even ex posted waves that can be quite
important that there needs to be a
strategy for that right away still stay
on the very short-term view when a
system is better at bringing food and
water that it is a brilliant health care
because we do not have operational
health interventions an organization the
same way we have a World Food Program or
UNHCR and we're seeing really a
disastrous situation in basic health
provision right now which will get worse
because there are lots of different
people they will not get follow-up and
so forth wh 0 it's not an operational
organizations in orbit about
organization we don't have a wfp
equivalent right now this is something
that absolutely needs addressing in
hours and days not in weeks and months
because large numbers obliged what we
lost I received a rather shocking email
by a orthopedic team that went to Haiti
and left he posed nothing was
at all for that to be effective from the
most basic supplies the most basic
orientation of most basic health from
any agency and so forth and it was
rather from dramatic because as with
many people setting in supplies and they
could get no support from anybody to do
anything and they just left them on
their own so another point that i want
to emphasize is that haiti is a rural
country still even more so obviously
after this disaster but it was about
two-thirds of the population working in
agriculture at least part-time or
full-time peasant farmers or part-time
farming and this needs to be attended to
haiti needs to feed itself and it's the
predominant livelihood for the country
the rainy season the planting season
starts in eight weeks the definition of
haiti smallholder farmer is it almost no
improved input farming this is a
disaster in haiti the farmers are
getting about 800 kilograms of cereal
production per hectare whereas in the
Dominican Republic it's 4.5 tons 4,500
kilograms per hectare the overwhelming
difference there is that Haitian farmers
do not have access to approve seed and
for
lizer I would strongly recommend as
absolutely key intervention for the next
six months to move shifts with
fertilizer at sea right now no more
missions just send the ships because I
know the food security system of the UN
it could take three planting seasons to
get something done and what's needed is
bags of fertilizer distributed through
the villages of the countryside now so
we ought to get on the phone with
Monsanto and with the mosaic and with
John and others and get the shipments of
fertilizer and seed will be right now so
that this country can feed itself and
without a further delay and I am working
on that I hope the UN will work on that
this is urgent now there is no agency
that does this FAO talked about 23
million dollar project is part of the
flash appeal it's just a tiny part and
FAO is also not much of an operational
organization it's more the normative
organization so we had to go very
quickly canoe at different ways this
country cannot live on food rations
coming from outside it's an unbelievable
waste of money effort loss of patience
till loss of patient livelihoods loss of
patient baby the loss of nutrition
everything let's get inputs to the
farmers immediately and by the way when
this is done in equally poor
institutionally deficient settings like
Malawi you double the food production in
a simple matter within months or weeks
it does not case studies does it make
world
missions doesn't take long planet it
takes dropping off of 50 kilo bag of
fertilizer for each of each household so
that plan under a half hectare farm so I
want to insist on that is something that
can be done there that should be done
very very quickly the next phase and now
be brief of others is the reconstruction
and development aspects these are two
distinct activities and that's why we
have a reconstruction and development in
the name of the world bank itself as the
International Bank for Reconstruction
development formal name of the World
Bank there is a rebuilding and as a
development phase we need to keep both
abuse in mind we shouldn't talk about
helping Haiti simply to rebuild because
that would redo it to the most extreme
poverty and vulnerability of the western
hemisphere which is no answer for this
country we should talk about helping
Haiti to get on a path of true
sustainable development and that
requires a different kind of approach
the experience from the Hurricanes of
2008 to the earthquake period was not a
happy period I want to stress almost
nothing happened in
national response I do this for a living
nothing moved not that nothing happened
because asians were doing things but the
international community barely
functioned to actually help I went for
more conferences more meetings or more
speeches read more reports grow more
reports without anything actually
happening that's how the international
system unfortunately works with its
cash-strapped and meetings are cheap
real development a is more expensive so
let me talk about the money we need to
before the cameras go out we need to put
some real money into this the cameras
are already getting turned off he will
be a forgotten issue it weeks even with
something of this magnitude right now
everybody wants to plant the flag to
show how they're the best friends of a
country that they've ignored for decades
if they really want to help put money in
a bank account my recommendation is put
it at the inter-american development
bank because it's the most professional
institution with a full-time
responsibility for development finance
for Haiti of any institution the World
Bank has too many things going on in the
world whereas the IED is created for
this purpose and it's been a good friend
Katie of all the international agencies
with financing operational
responsibilities the UN knows a lot of
crucial things but it doesn't do
large-scale finance for that we need an
international fan
institution and I would recommend the
inter-american Development Bank so my
strong recommendation is we put some
billions of dollars there without that I
fear if we're going back to mythology
soon don't count on the private sector
rescuing don't count on bilateral donor
agents are very interested don't count
on them even being able to move money
because they don't move money it takes
forever they're 23 bilateral donor
agencies there are another 15 or 20
multilateral institutions engaged right
now UN agencies and so forth
coordination is nearly impossible over
any long term so I believe we need one
multi-donor fun with the real money
there as the counterpart of the
government of heat so that the
government of Haiti has a chance to
actually get the financing that it needs
to really get this done the u.s. I've
been through many cycles of Haiti not
been activity expert but I've been
through many cycles who many are skied
governments and many other governments
the US will lose interest quickly that's
harsh parcel of our political system so
the money better get there in the bank
and I would strongly urge President
Obama to appropriate right now a
supplemental appropriation or put it in
the budget coming out next week of at
least a billion dollars this year a
billion dollars next year not through
USAID not through us institutions but in
a multi-donor account if he really wants
to show America carrots take it out of
the US government US government can come
in and work but it will otherwise Titus
the nuts for a long time all the donors
want to do their own thing right now and
we just need one thing done which is
Haitian government leadership to help
get certain key things on the way what
are the costs of this let me just give
you a very rough guess nobody knows of
course but just a rough guess president
prval ask tatiana me over the summer to
help scope out development issues for
the country and our estimate was that
the normal development assistance would
be between one and one and a half
billion dollars a year as the need for
normal development aid that's compared
to actual development aid of about three
hundred million dollars a year and
another emergency 250 300 per year and
minustah about 600 million a year so
total spending on haiti up to the
earthquake was about 1.2 billion a year
one-quarter of which i will count as
development assistance one-quarter of
which i would count as emergency health
food aid and so forth and one half of
which was peacekeeping operations the
actual development aid probably needs to
be four or five times that about it even
before the earthquake one to
one-and-a-half billion a year for many
years to come that's to build roads
power clinics schools agricultural
capability and so forth that was a
pretty good calculation that fit in well
with the amounts that one would see in
other countries how about reconstruction
it's anybody's guess because this
take careful engineering and so forth
but my guess part of anybody's guess is
five to ten billion dollars required
maybe two billion for housing another
billion for roads and another couple of
billion for other parts of clearing and
key infrastructure hospitals schools
government buildings and so forth but it
could be 10 billion probably not 15 or
20 billion for the reconstruction part
then there is a third category which is
four people left destitute and in need
of relief or further health emergencies
and so forth and I put that at about a
million dollars this year which matches
the flash appeal for you n which is half
a million over six months I put it at 1
billion over a year and then tapering
off graduate if I add all those pieces
my completely literally back at the
envelope because that's where it was
first on it was a back of an envelope is
about three billion dollars per year 1
billion for reconstruction 1 billion for
relief and 1 billion for development and
those numbers would continue in a
slightly different way more for
development over time less for relief
but that to my mind is roughly in order
of magnitude that's a pretty modest sum
for what's at stake maybe it's too low
it's not too high an estimate but it's
much more than will actually get
unless we put a new institutional frame
around it what will normally get if we
continue the normal way we're doing
right now it's a few hundred million of
Public relief through the public appeals
and that will be for relief operations
and NGOs and we will get maybe a few
hundred million for reconstruction
financing and development financing will
turn out to be very rigid and very hard
at home unless there's a conscious
understanding of linking all of these
things together so let me close by
hoping that what all of the
organizations and agencies could do is
agree I Asian government leadership
integration of relief reconstruction of
development and creating a multi-donor
fund to facilitate this process being
honest with ourselves of how hard it is
unless we do something unusual and
paving the lesson from the Hurricanes up
to the earthquake or nothing moved and
understanding we need a new approach
actually bait the financing move and to
fit these various categories and finally
I just want to emphasize one more time
the rains start in about eight weeks
that means risks for populations shelter
flooding hurricanes and it also means
opportunity for planting and we should
be attuned to that timetable because
that's the real life
it's opening presentation this is also a
fundraising event and it is a
fundraising going to the calculus of
health and the reason why we decided to
do that is that you probably saw that
all the pictures that will solve there
was a tenant with cars and a lot of
wounded coming and I just want to
reinforce virgin were singing about the
month of health capacity anyway had it
was absolutely nothing there there were
a few bandages that water container as
the attendance of wounded curry the only
one goes we'll be partners in health so
our fundraising tinnitus with them our
personal injury she wanted to add
something to watch everton in focus I'd
like to begin by saying virgin yeah hey
a 200 year old world system problem that
has needed serious attention you know
she has been at this crossroad between
deprivation absolute decline for a very
long time and to understand what needs
to happen I think we must digest much of
what a definite just noted the promising
indie and all of its development two
nations to understand that crucially and
fundamentally the problem is an
organizational one the first 100 years
of its inception and thereafter between
fitting office first
before did defending its independence in
under 100 year old embargo had never had
time to organize in society so he never
organized himself socially economically
spatially not even culture and a sense
of how institutions framework seems to
go forward so I agree with what Jeff
said I have been pounding at this for
the last 20 years it is not a country to
be reconstructed piece of country to be
constructed from from the very beginning
as we speak so right after this relief
face and the relief phase also has
actually mean to undertake this to be
fundamentally insert it into the idea
that the national stage of economic
development planning is the first policy
to go
and by that I mean that the organization
problem has to be resolved within he it
has to find a way for that society to
come out organizing itself at its own
village and hence my worry hence not
worry through the UN system through the
u.s. system and if we in the smooth
event universe that operated and in
Haiti and that there hasn't been an
innocent in the very well that I new
earth that foreign entities go about
building a country and letting the
country be healed by its own village
it's the real problem because Haitians
deeply want to participate in all phases
of their relief recovery and development
and if I've been all set they are not
integrated fully integrated in these
processes them involved because there
are fiercely independent proud you're
rowing and it's but yet they need the
assistance the assistance
has to come in the way of my almost of
caressing because it is remember it's a
country distinct isolate its nice
hundred year and then thereafter it has
been held in contempt almost and so it's
also their into it they're very it's
going to be a very sensitive way of
foreign entities to help her out this
development if it is to happen in His
image by by Haitian people and building
it from the spirit of Haitian people
that has never happened and I don't
understand from my experience have been
waitin a Baltimore social system
structure of Haiti scanning you know all
ten Department surveying the Haitians
the patient population of asking them
what is there a difference iety in
understanding that ideal society is not
usually the image nor cultural reality
that is not in the image of formal
entities who conduct development work in
practice so home it means this type of
development in which we're talking about
post relief needs to be done with a lot
of hand-holding a lot of patients
require a lot of time and a lot of money
and to understand fundamentally the
dynamics and Haitian society right now
as it exists and to understand that the
Federation is so traumatized so that you
have to take into consideration as your
address as we rebuild it or building
rather and as you organizing Society
genomically socially we also have to
organize it culture lane by hunter here
I excellent read institutions that
provide moral support to keep up the
courage at home patient people always
say where there's life there's hope and
you fundamentally
like there's hoping they'll keep on
pushing back home but yet every
institution that we know of in
port-au-prince has collapse the schools
have collect the churches have collapse
the government buildings have collapsed
the church is actually extremely
important because of the Catholic Church
more especially it's time to the Voodoo
religion so if you can go to the
cathedral on to worship to give to the
poor which is a big you know ility the
a-league season which is in November
huge beating we never think about these
things if you can't go to sick Joseph or
since and it's these the links of class
and so understanding the gravity of all
of these institutions that have
collapsed and they worked well organized
to begin with and now I have to reshape
organize it but in a way that the
Haitian people will feel that is their
own that takes a lot of patience and I
am Not sure that we've had the type of
technical this sort of you know it's
beyond just pure technicality is sort of
very caring technocracy whether it's PA
whether it's via USAID we've never no
one is ever thought a nation society so
if it is to happen now anybody's to have
it now but yet it themselves with on the
ground they have a problem there are a
coordination and so how do we begin to
push or to advocate for the need for
national development national spatial
economic development sweetly spatially I
said needs to be development in they
have and not just the play focused on
sexual development because I join you
have to understand that the ten
departments of Haiti or very distinct
actually they've been isolated but
physically physically because of our
range of mountains in the way or rivers
off so the tent departments physically
or isolated from one another where we're
by the North the northern folks have 20
different temperaments than the southern
folks or the landmark folks which live
by the border they speak realized
Spanish robotics right so it's a very
end so without understanding the
dynamics in the commonalities what makes
nation identity strong and great and
what also separate them for in order for
you to come out with a cohesive society
that has just been traumatized and it
really shaken
present down to you know to the last man
and I my lesson my my real worried that
how do we begin to end which entity you
know it is the IDP and a carry and you
know while it's only money how you know
how do we be what entity do we trust for
implementing such a reconstruction and
development and in our discussions we
think there has to be a high commission
on reconstruction and development I've
made up by Haitian people of course was
bolstered heavily with for an expert
because you need relax you know the
Bureau of Statistics lost all its all
its people including you retrained of
SATA stations that we've just found
innovation to adjust trained in the
United States at went back lost so of
course we need the expertise but they
have to walk in hand in hand that
medications were left and Haiti we want
to participate in it and also combined
with the Haitian diaspora you've got a
large Haitian diaspora that is ready to
go back home I mean I became a player to
go plan for my country until and there's
for that way and ready to go until the
concern that to Rapa is that the concern
has to be assistant and a systemic
approach to development and starting
with relief efforts through the
reconstruction effort to through the
development which requires a map of a
you know the plane I foresee is a
blueprint from which not only can we
organize the difference in development
dimensions by that any the economically
the social the cultural and the
political but also within that of all
the actors will know what their roles
you know how they play in the rose and
jump like all kinds of rubble sinking
the UN system for your cars are rotating
and the coordination is nearly up
because they they have not been gazing
ever been a national plan within which
everyone find themselves
she wanted to see something
thank you very much all set
or for the invitation but also a week
ago I'm very pleased that you began with
our patient colleagues because so few
over yet son hated begin the patients
and I think the two teachers that just
gave us a sense of that Weston air in
the room excuse me to say Jeff SAT
cetacean for the record he's not for our
colleagues and and for Jeff with the
travel exemption I think this is the
right way to begin this discussion he is
a devastated country today there is no
doubt about that it is a country that is
in mourning but has no
morning people having to work through
daily survival issues even as they lost
many loved ones at some very profound
level all of my colleagues at the UN can
empathize very sincerely both because of
the presence in Haiti but because of our
own losses I think the working wounded
if you will is something that we are
sharing all too much these days with the
people of haiti but there is also a a
series burner only way I think it has a
secret just mention the UN has for
various reasons ended up playing many
key roles in the country of Haiti and
when we heard that there was a
significant quite 10 days ago we kicked
our systems into gear to start planning
what could be done to help haiti and not
realizing that the very people we were
counting on to execute that for under
tons of rubble but it shows the problem
that we are facing right now can play
our fundamental and normal international
organizational role pulling all the
international
actors together Haiti because of the
situation that was just described has a
an unbelievable array of international
actors acting inside 80 in normal times
and today it has gotten much more
dramatic with various efforts pouring it
from all over with no centralized
ordination to speak up and this is the
reality of what my colleagues in the UN
are trying to pull together just the
international response is a challenge I
don't want to repeat a number of things
have been said so I won't try to cover
everything but I want to make a few
credit points maybe that haven't been
mentioned in terms of immediate needs
just to give you a sense of the scope of
what hate is facing right now the food
needs and their normal times it is
considered that 1.8 million
patients are food insecure in that nice
technocratic language of the
international community that means one
little shove and you don't eat and
unfortunately we just had a big show the
current estimates for immediate food
needs are two million people right now
we have scaled up food assistance in
unbelievable time given the lack of
infrastructure the lack of the people
who were killed in the quake that are
needed to organize this international
community has responded very smartly on
the food front but we've only reached
about 500,000 people and this is as fast
as anyone can go and has ever gone I
would say to get food assistance into a
devastated area but we need to know
really yesterday but what kind of food
assistance we are piling up in
warehouses you know rice and beans and
all the things that you normally a lot
but there are no there is no capacity to
cook and hate the systems that would
provide the fuels that are needed to
cook aren't there the forests are
the transportation isn't there to get
what is there to the right places so if
you have a bunch of brains that mean
cooking but you don't have the ability
to cook them that food present too much
good which shows the systems problem
this isn't just about inputs and getting
bags of X Y or Z to the right place you
actually need to approach the immediate
needs from a science perspective on how
to get everything you need you need the
supply lines you need the security you
need the goods you need the other books
that will help you prepare those goods
so just to take the immediate food needs
it shows not only that the systems that
did exist have been devastated but that
what we are trying to provide a haiti is
not always going to be able to be used
if we don't think this through from that
systems perspective to just give you a
sense another sense of the scope of what
we're facing right now you hadn't put
out a call man
coordinator protocol in Montreal today a
global appeal for meals ready-to-eat for
this very reason that there is no
ability to prepare food for millions of
people right now there are not enough
identified identified meals ready to eat
in the world right now for hate not
enough meals ready-to-eat identified
that we had for hey for one country
that's how dub marion this quake is in
the volume that we're talking about
under normal circumstances many
countries 10 scores or countries have
meals ready to eat in their military
leader humanitarian operations and
having tapped out everything that we
have we know how to put out a global
call for everyone to go into their
stocks go into their warehouses and find
more meals ready to eat because he needs
those down and it's not with a real
alternative for the time being that's
the surgery just how overwhelming this
is but we can't forget water when
providing one for 235,000 people now
that's even a fraction of what is
necessary shelter provided probably
about temporary facilities for about
350,000 now it's safe to say that that
at least six to eight hundred thousand
identified need additional temporary
shelter right now Jeff SAT spoke a bit
about the medical situation medical
services and I think the problem that he
defined is a very real one there's no
centralized Authority in either in Haiti
or in the international community would
comfort Emergency Medical Response and
therefore these stories of these
emergency medical teams coming in while
it might sound grow up the fact is not
mud doesn't surprise me at all to hear
the critical thinker then walking away
because again they don't have a place to
plug in their generators they don't have
all the things baby the function so we
do need to look at the entire medical
and public health arena has a special
area of need in the coming days and
weeks not just the booths issue not just
been
and what
the input we need the actress systems
and that is not something that's
mobilized quickly or easily I won't say
much about the security challenge
because I I think jean-marie gano is is
the right one to address this but to
just give you a sense of what is going
right in right now while the stands of
journalists who descended on hey have
been looking for and finding isolated
incidents of violence so far that's what
they are isolated incidents of violence
if you can imagine what has happened to
Haiti the fact of the discipline ND
relative calm that exists in haiti today
i'll be in a very fragile very fragile
column is really quite impressive and I
think it's impressive first and foremost
for the Haitian people and what they are
doing to maintain their daily in their
home under extraordinary circumstances
but it is also a testament to the United
Nations as devastated
East in Haiti was as devastated as the
international police forces and Ed have
been decapitated there we go does the
fact is that the UN and the troops and
the police that view it has on the
ground working with those elements of
the Haitian National Police that are
still functioning have been able to keep
relative calm wouldn't have that if you
watched American television but that is
the fact of it that if there is a
remarkable conflict situation that we're
experiencing right now one other area
that I'd like to mention in order to
empower patients to take control of your
lives the need to make sure that those
systems which did exist do start
functioning is absolutely certain it's
been very encouraging in recent days
that there is some some food appearing
in markets in street corners again
very small quantities but to see normal
systems reasserting themselves the
problem of course is that so if you have
money to be able to access what food
does exist the with the help of minister
in the DP colleagues they've been able
to help to reopen 47 banks in the last
10 days since the earthquake this may
not sound like much but having 47
branches upon which people can draw
their money not only allows some normal
systems to start functioning for food
for water the like but it also helps
give people a sense that there is a
system and so things like banks look
really do matter people but then look to
people who don't have banks or bank
accounts what are the systems that we
need to reestablish immediately to give
patients a sense of control of their own
destiny so they aren't just lining up in
Food lines in front of international
volunteers another challenge i'd like to
just mention that i'm afraid we're going
to be hearing a lot more about in the
coming days and weeks is a tremendous
situation of internally
people the fact is that in order to deal
with the tremendous problems in
port-au-prince the government has been
assisting people 28 artprints there are
at least two hundred and thirty-five
thousand people we've been able to count
who are now living in places where they
don't have any any connection to and
therefore and that's drawing by the day
and therefore those populations are over
they are a specific population of great
glory and it's growing by the day and
it's happening in different parts of the
country so then you have to be able to
reach them in different places so the
IDP problems are very real now maybe
just a couple final observations and one
is already run a few of how to achieve
multiple things at one time we have to
look for interventions that can achieve
multiple things that we don't have the
luxury of just focusing on single issues
one of those kind of important
interventions it's going to identify
no is being able to get the food for
work and cash for work programs up and
running these are the programs that in
any situation anywhere in the world are
never funded no governor wants to give
money for cash for work it's a it's a
born loser handing over a bunch of cash
to people that you can't get receipts
from be able to account to your
accountants that you paid certain amount
to certain people it just has moral
hazard written all over it and yet
there's nothing more necessary right now
because it's not just that services need
to be delivered and rubble needs to be
cleared and people need to be found and
that the person power to do that is that
Haitian people are very important people
to do that but you do need to be able to
pay them for that work and in so doing
give them a hand in their own recovery
there are people wandering all over the
streets today they cannot continue to
wander and one and be an aimless they
have something
new in reconstructive in the country so
getting the cash flow work and the food
for programs up and running immediately
is essential i will say that prior to
the experience in painting we had a
previous requests for food for work
after the last major earthquake in
pakistan and exactly zero percent but
responded exactly zero it is hard but it
is it is extraordinary extraordinary
circumstance of whatever most immediate
needs and something that we are focused
on very strong right now finally just
enclosing a word about a word that I've
heard tonight in various speakers and it
could not be more true worship in our
daily lives we don't get to have too
many heroes in our lives i think in the
21st century i daresay if anyone around
the room sits around and tries to think
about how many people they really
heroes in their lives it's probably not
a tremendously long list I will tell you
from what we have seen in Haiti in the
last 10 days the list of patient heroes
and the list of international heroes the
list of helium heroes is the mall and
deep and what we need to do is capture
that spirit and extend it into these big
systems problems the fundamental systems
problems of haiti and the fundamental
systems problems of the international
community is very struck by the comment
that this is kind of a
two-hundred-year-old international
organization problem this is our chance
to try to turn this around both but the
Haitians turn their country in a new
direction but the international
community has to have a new relationship
with a very different relationship with
Hayden
past and it's this heroism on which I
think we can build it has a
transformative character anyone who
Civic is affected by it and motivated by
and we need hope we need motivation and
we need staying power and the number of
speakers have talked about this is the
moment driver- ticket in the ice or any
more than just a getting money in the
price we need to organize ourselves in a
way that is sustained so that hey you
will not go on accompany one week from
there one month from now six months from
now five years from now hey we'll need
accompaniment on this extraordinary
journey back but i think if we can
capture and analyze the spirit of the
heroism that we've seen their abilities
have started
I was very much like to keep some time
for questions and all similar to do have
many soon I we did refer to a passive a
pattern who has a decided to show the
example and only speak for a few minutes
I thank you i can see the quad right in
front of me so convenient reminder first
up I just like thank you xterra pendants
for the comments I think it sees its
associated I'd like to start by disaster
how many people would make that been in
a decision okay a good representative
sample i started working in 1819
elections which were they were the sort
of breakout moment from the country was
hoping the reverse its two interviewers
of exploitation
kind of rule then 1994 after right after
the US invasion I was able to leave the
multilateral team that sent up offices
in 13 different parts of the country and
we also worked i met a local governance
program which is very much driven by
what local people wanted as opposed to
the prescription that we came anyway and
we also worked on civilizing the Haitian
military which was a much reviled
institution at that time so had a really
a wonderful chances as those of you
raise your hands to make a feeling for
the country and
deep deep respect for the people and the
creativity
very very trying the best of
circumstance also a feeling for your
scripts to ask for that we've got to
know how the world I think described
reason I'd like to say something about
what the United States is trying to do
now Amanda stop it if I have more than a
minute to offer for rules welcome back
to those if the time is short I think
what you're seeing right now in for the
United States government is really
unprecedented response it is sincere it
is eager to focus on the Haitian people
it makes committed to working with the
Haitian government at all levels it is
it believes and UN leadership out of
this and it is not just going through
the motions and it's doing everything
that our government is capable of doing
others have spoken about many of our
shortcomings that they are evident to
all of us but the sincerity of the
simpler and believed
should be coordinating mall it is
genuine and when I've seen people who
that when I'm sorry turns over the last
week when I've seen disappointments when
I see fatigue I have also seen everybody
making one more effort to make sure that
it wasn't personalized that we didn't
get into the usual back and forth and I
think that that quality is very much
driven by President Obama's commitment
and the guidance to working in on a
daily basis do not let the usual
tensions which happened in a situation
like this where people are clearly under
a tremendous amount of pressure to do
the nearly impossible in the time that's
really not available so it has been a
very positive outpouring is still plenty
more to do and what I would say is we go
hook ahead to the reconstruction this is
something or the construction however
you want to call it this is something
that I worked on in 30 countries all
over the world over the last 20 years
but there is clearly no silver bullet we
have to bring any port first we have to
find ways and power
we are used to doing heard a number of
good ideas in that regard and we really
have to be catalytic competitor guard
and so I would put at the very top of
the list public safety rule of law first
because people have to have an
environment to think of working secondly
we have to be very opportunistic in our
governing starters we have to take
wherever they are because the central
government is going to take a long time
to get itself back together and this is
a building period third we have to
extend individual choice of the cash
programs really absolutely wonderful
they've worked in the paxton
earth-quaking before wasn't responsive
food for working and Kosovo in other
places and then we have to keep our
larger plans extremely simple chaos
requires a simple response if it gets
too exotic you're likely right control
so look forward to your questions and
comments
Pakistani it has to be better and even
children what kind of this evening
operation do with the peacekeeping
operation that has been decapitated last
video best people people who ratted care
and the humility to help to work with
evasion first of course people see with
blue helmets people with soldiers with
guns to see these offices they bring
first in terms of security and indeed
there is a role there and in this time
the pastor's play the role in securing
places where there were gangs and but I
very much agree with but with what Baba
was said and what actually Commissioner
Kelly said right after the earthquake as
he was coming back from Haiti that this
whole notion that violence was going to
break was a deep miss reading of what da
shins are in New York I think they are
like 34,000 police at any time or more
and this is a city that got what about
but this is the number required to keep
it safe Haiti has been remarkably say
considering the circumstances
exceptionally say so indeed they may be
a tantra need for secular groups are
more importantly police but I i don't
think that security is the greatest
contribution that Minister can make I
think the most important issue in a way
for the leadership of the mission for a
minute today yes I want to be
paradoxical but in a way is to find the
natural flow of the international
community and to help the Haitians get a
grip and rain the international
community to do to help do what that
China was saying it needs to be done
this year and I had not noticed it's
any who wrote to me that just before he
died they were going to be three
elections in Haiti logistic vote on the
Constitution and presidential narrow so
a huge the series of an action equals it
be mother of all elections here in a way
it's a reflection of what the China was
saying the whole question of
organization how does that society come
together I think that you are there in
the peacekeeping mission they have a
role in working out with the Haitian
authorities the kind of structures that
will be needed to manage that agency and
to go against the flow it out in the
more specific he has no no is it is a
country where as again that can I said
has been a huge imbalance and it's it's
not normal in a country that the capital
city & 3 million people essentially a
third or more other country it's it's
huge this is an enormous is balance
between power pass and the other cities
become three power powers in the
countryside and so they're going to be
strategic choices that the government
have healthy we'll make do you want to
want to rebuild both houses more than a
third of the country there's one plan
for Haiti this is a different
relationship between perhaps and the
rest of the other country the natural
tendency of the international committee
will be to focus on power plants that's
what that's what happened before the
earthquake that's what will happen after
the earthquake and remember in Haiti and
being struck by the fact that
ninety-five percent of international aid
was focused on power plants he went to
when I went to cafe she is so very few
international actually to big cities
sacrifice if you went further in the in
the countryside so nobody that's a real
that's a real issue can do un help this
the Haitian government fight against
them can they even help fight against
the dominance of cities versus the
countryside and there was mention of the
activity which used to be a great rice
producing mention but were the old
irrigation all at
in overtime through neglect lack of
resources essentially mean that the
terrible figures that were being
mentioned by gently sucks on the on the
productivity thus is one ready to help
the countryside's more complicated than
just pouring in principles I think
they're the UN can help what structures
and then I'm not I don't know enough to
know exactly how to put together but I
think something along the lines of what
was done in the Marshall Plan contact so
it's very different in Europe you had a
lot of educated people much more than
you have in a tea but nevertheless Joint
Commission's where you combine measure
of international expertise with firms
with Haitians also you mobilize the
jaspera when you think that the Diaspora
BTW i think dreams about more than a
billion of billion two dollars every
year to haiti if there is an increase in
those fun which is or which is already
very generous from the gas profit and
say there's that there was an exception
include which is possible but for a fun
priety managed co-manage with the
variation and it's a very politically
sensitive issue the balance between the
role the Diaspora and the nation's y NT
all has needs to be managed with great
care and delicacy but i think that's
where an enlightened leadership of UN
mission can help find the time so that
the ancients
and build a hickey that will be
different from the hating that suffered
the earthquake which for me is only half
natural disaster it's a disaster that in
the country that had the structures the
political stance on political structures
to deal with that disaster it would have
been a terrible tragedy indeed but in a
different order of magnitude and so the
role of the political side of you were
in the peacekeeping operation now for me
it's to look at the systems and to help
the Haitians build systems that will not
avoid future natural disasters but that
will change the order of magnitude the
impact of those disasters thank you
I wasn't a student you know I didn't
like that have a chance to talk i will
just may be complimented you but have
some questions that is what we emphasize
that you know that is very important
legal amazingly for tourists wise
because it's you know their world and
it's necessary and we work better let's
a go because all the considerations
regarding makers so complex you know
that only the people that are never able
to find the solution to the
proliferative text we kind of of course
support technically and whatever we want
but they are at once we will find a way
to get it on the second one zero matter
of us videos and say that really like us
well they would have to make an effort
to have recovery process where you know
people at the center of the construction
you know they are the center of the
destruction they are the center of the
democracy why were we as weak as it can
be still system democracy and I thing in
the process of the construction should
strengthen is this kind of process and
they should be like at the center of a
consultation the participation
definition of
instruction and then diagnosis and all
the organizations to be accountable to
people and such a by the US ports and I
think this is something that important
they're very good example and many other
places and we have to so just just to
mention two things you know I'm sure the
process is not going to be easy it's
going to be very difficult now the
reason we copy today this is a test for
more that five thousand people reading
today working on basketball programs
would be 10,000 by name of the year the
name of the week we get to maybe in 100
150 thousand appoint matter of weeks so
that's going to be important to morning
communication you know many other things
that will make it with that isn't going
to be perfect doesn't point to happen
it's never perfect all the money we may
look there may be problems along the
line but it will happen will happen
because before the crisis Haiti was the
growth to the public and was you know
reaching some positive growth going to
be involved three percent fe as you it
was some investments coming to the plan
things it was hoping I only went down
dramatically and do some extended you
could see a collective effort began to
move forward and show that as soon as
you know we are able to move forward
with the construction process they
recover the hope that they need to move
forward with it with an on the vellum
and we want to do is support financially
technically but I have different figures
and things like that that I you know I
prefer to lead a different question
I'm going to open a lot of questions but
I just wanted to highlight once it has
been said to learn which to me is the
most difficult thing and probably will
arrive as the peacekeeping operation can
we focus its emphasis there but how do
we use this rebuilding so to speak to
make sure that the policy to have a
voice in the reconstruction to me this
is such a ticket it sounds easy but it
isn't and I'm sure phasellus i forgot to
say city society go but how can we make
this happen that parsley painting was
more in the hands of a few of the elite
and this is not only haiti can really
have a process where the people of haiti
are involved to me this is really the
question that are applied to ask to
everyone and how do we encourage this
and how do we help the people to have a
voice and to have a say what they are
going to do next and that we would be
using a crisis as
and I just wanted to finish say that so
now we open the door to the floor to the
question you go there and you introduced
no are we have it okay can you introduce
yourself and also say there is one
particular speaker would like to ask
sure did you some trends in order to
make those fantasy that's good to be
back and just follow your comment to
alien colonists is that I was really
oughta to click one sentence also follow
the moisture management isn't a lot of
students are also gross hydrates at ceva
very close to this and we as in truffles
from hands in August and come directly
involved in Hannity and so I watched it
sort of changing because Bobby mentioned
and says couple colleagues and myself on
having to do actually and short-term and
longer-term to simple development work
in Haiti you've already
compartments working more than piety
specifically for medical aid and
supplies and I resolve its opportunity
to say it we're all want to do something
and we are so related but this is your
opportunity you comments updates at this
period facing is booked if you guys want
to get involved after this meeting under
this event the each time we we can take
from them to action something as unity
include municipal don't have too much
time because I'm sure somebody's you
need to push us out of it so it makes
you a question very short don't make it
exclusive oh god I am engine and I have
two thousand eight seven countries I
have two questions the first question I
begin to add the haitian palace we all
understand that Asian has to be part of
the solution and we have to lead the way
but open time and he that hatred as a
trusted government about rebuilding that
country when they should open day and
you know Madison open head and they
don't look at government as the solution
because they open see the government has
a bottom so do you know you should pay
the government to take the money and
pretty penny something you know college
insulin or item social isolation and the
coastal price and that's you know that's
a good question because often times it
does have it are we the government can
actually what occasion to be a trust so
that's the first question the second
question is pocketed ask for agent asked
one was spinning at rebuilding process
while we know that we should contribute
to one trait or DGP at this isn't about
1.9 billion dollars were sent back asian
ass work but they are new voice or no se
and is immediately how the green becomes
a lose-lose situation something to do
few questions
I think it will be such a question you
have because the record and in fact it
under sort of traditional Asian
government as a nominee super up and so
you responsible that providing support
to the government of 80 would
essentially it will spend any money
unwisely he said the following i think
has been mentioned here it has been
noticed in the last three years so that
he has been much progress respect to the
ability of the government to rise up
slowly and small step yo game and this
is part of the reason why I children's
for example to be part of the government
at a particular point in time I
led the National Coalition price facing
Europe was quite a number of years in
challenging I'm gonna be honest policy
and what is as itself many of the
policies in fact and and never thought
of myself as being part of institution
that has such a bad reputation but given
the one worth going on last year which
was increasingly short so I think I'm
gonna be one has become one more open to
your ears more more open to providing a
stable environment in which
contributions could be made both respect
to the private sector initiative
incident that I thought that this was in
fact an opportunity to get involved let
me say this there is no way of getting
around the fact that another for a
country to grow you need a government
institution the government is essential
question that becomes are the
responsibilities are meant to be as open
as grammar to you that is reflected into
them the couple choices the fellow who
has let me conduct guide that composite
of several years in speculative in
population passport the fellow who had
no education abroad use also to be the
person who fought heavily enough for
Asian rice in public as join the
government and has been in fact more
open to involve working together on a
ways in which will increase the robbing
of the nation
astral I truly believe validation data
store is going to be a huge asset to the
people of haiti and that there needs to
be the skills and competence and wizard
that they can bring to bear on the
challenging that we focus on is abusing
are much bigger today that they were in
fact earlier but these are the
challenges that are going to test you
they are gonna test whether or not you
are speaking and really ready are ready
to one of these things or you are simply
standing by and being passive while
others will take my sensor is that it is
now your oven to get I guess I just want
to reiterate I just want to do the
Jasper on our first question to Charlie
you know the government has always been
very very weak for a very long time if
it means the Diaspora to also meet
halfway and you know in the same thing
that's happening in haiti happens in the
jaspera it started before organization
there's a social contract that means
happen within the Jasper community in
two weeks Fletcher and none of the
Jasper community itself much like the
Indian diaspora it's done the Armenian
Jasper of course of different reason
that have to come together under one
goal not being centered between my any
pretensions bouts of contention to your
contention and we call you know we know
why the problems exist so there have
been so many times for converses trying
to come to the commonality but what's
that one purpose that the Jasper uniweb
stop 10 again I go back to that national
special economic development because
that himself and compasses are covers
the how r what role is our Jasper going
to play but also it has to meet the
government halfway how organized have
the Jasper itself in to insert itself in
this correct role in Haiti it's a
two-way street it can't just be a
one-way street and leadership is taken
not given
the next question yes my name is Tom
Ransome adult journalist and I didn't
back from Haiti this weekend and I was
probably one of the few Jeremy's it was
there during the earthquake we're doing
went to the group of asian century are
doing a couple projects which that's
something to do german a PR candy
cigarette and i'm also inside by the way
to make increased iphone you can get a
little culture sorry I patience they
come in a step and I just one gives you
a few most days of trying to be 30
seconds while you're there and probably
my office you got very angry about how
slowly labels and the I was their own
behalf as a human breast card costs only
asked Fanny for two days hospitals to
get nervous class or stack up the polity
seven to the airport and clearly that is
till friday is we have a surprised
organization like it I mean it's really
about that scandal how all the meetings
over horny neighbors and all these views
of people in the SUV women in the
Hamptons on fourth july agrahara and
since an eight
so so and people whose lives because the
medical necessity health care my other
concern is that is huge again a shoe in
some tasting more hearty good when
you've all talked about these spots you
have to remember that nobody knew at the
point before they all did what was
difficult the Astra food is abundant
within many food transportation from
Fred battle with root canals also not
last a ground fighting suit from heaven
work bc by because the rice exhibit in
miami rises given is sewing and it's all
right i mean how do you fit for our life
sorry Haiti I mean so the emphasis in
that all supplied is wrong yet what is
easy to tackle food is not any people
you wanted right they're all super of
charcoal fires it's not if you're not
the street oratory how to meet some
different so you have to take these
things in boxes and my fear is that
enormous amount of money that goes into
say organizer have seen it conducts 830
her dates dr. any resident
any better situation it's too early no
operation say no and so my weariness is
about how the big boys are happy and i
will say involve you you're concerned
arkady was not you maritime so you'd
indicated i would not omit the small
heroic organizations that you can work
here because i'm not too sure if you
know ed good bit he is really gonna help
you have to be smart out a name to be
very good and the last point does the
speaker said nobody has managed affected
eyes that they happen then apparently
Trump's government dat which has very
strong or credit balances it has
manipulated for the processes of our
staff of Monsters has made sure that and
number of files are not evolved into a
boss anymore the president has put
almost all his cronies every powerful
position of moments and you can only
been fascinated by Washington season in
Africa economic everybody talks about
first page applications ordinations and
wonder who is their representation it's
not this government
we have some comments American i have to
thank every one of you it's heartwarming
to know how much to say and for you to
begin today it's very very hot one and I
think it's a matter of my heart for
being here including for all of us even
when I think back baby because I was
trained as a lot of allergies and i
think but i think my thickness is all of
us we need to fit in the world why
because the same thing that happened in
he can happen in word and how would you
feel being the united states and being
in the same situation fitness so bad so
this is again why i say thank you
because i think that the world responded
because they old fitness is important so
on so survival in supporting my father
which is maximally which words are said
maxim
beyond what ho ho dai which was he was a
second hit of that organization he has
never been this we haven't had food
because my father would we got a picnic
up in the morning make sure that the
peasants and water and hot seats
everything I needed to actually made a
cultural food in the 1970s in divided
government who seemed album and last
American citizen and Anna here in Marin
County my father had everything legally
in his power to actually fit in the
Haitian people in the world with food in
his generation hydrogen now you can see
the situation that happened afterward
Here I am here and I was getting both I
knew that the Haitian guys for Eliza we
need to get organized yes this is one
that mentality also in his service
situation but how about really here how
about you making digestion and then
piggy within yourself indian sugar
in the comments to the next question I
have a simple pressure but I've not met
you it's a regiment citizen not a
reporter and I treat past when you hear
you know as my friend on New Year's it's
not there yet so i can assume mr. all
probably all we mentioned the what to
eat for baby now i am here video of 2235
dollars we're still connected or whole
heart to the set aside enough current
price in the next three to three months
to a year or further on and how is your
feelings of satisfied because i pair all
they wanted me gone in function over
Randy broken so that's my question and
if I have thomas's but too much can
share after you ask
Pablo might be able to answer on the
longer term water means but I think they
immediate water needs right now
estimated that at least the two million
people I do not have access to any form
of water they can count on right now
that's a tremendous amount of water
because unlike food which is easily
shippable water discontinuity systems
and congestion on the roads and places
water is one of the major problems right
now and of course if not addressed
immediately that can lead to a lot of
the public health challenges that we
could see
dramatic second wave of severe problems
for the population that opportunity well
make amends only that the racial
minority for the crisis almost
personally recently there have access to
what state as a result of his closest
will be updated some of these people
were pencil they need Simon measure now
is a disaster needs assessment which way
to access all business all nice and 25
in and there would be for the presenter
that we don't have any figures exactly
now as how much just one point two or
three one thing sorry about their i will
surely somebody in a Chicago setting a
radio in a patient also asian language
to associate expected a greater to money
to work can i really ask the students to
be short and not
edition with their questions because
they are Steven all were we have to we
have to leave the room very submix
question okay i'm actually a student at
the way look like one actually that
leaving an initiative in he that is to
develop a youth corps down there because
you know a lot of what we're talking
about is empowering the Haitian people
to be involved in this process but
generally that does that does involve a
government which is a very elite
educated small small percentage of the
Asian population and so that are doing
into building the capacity of the youth
to actually get the communities engaged
in grants which way and I would like to
know how it's possible to connect the
two to connect grass root movements
connect possibility with whatever it is
that is being planned by the
international community I thought you'd
answer that
you know USAID he just said thirty seven
thousand dollars on addition there's
some wacky idea get your youth together
to clean histories it doesn't work I
think you know we're talking about right
now development development of a country
takes systemic change qualitative and
quantitative no more NGO that we have a
this 10,000 NGOs working with more NGOs
in anyone in the world and he has nest
no you don't think what should be is a
National Development Corp some like
something like a corps of engineer but
something that a UN and another donor
community can help us put together very
much like a you know a military system
to it absorb patient labor train them
very well I mean real training as if
they're going to not only dress boot
camp but actually go into school trained
and send them out to do the work the
environmental we fail you a
reforestation that we need oh and we're
talking to a youth program a national
program these you
you talk about come in and out it has
been trying since the 1970s because what
happens is it on average the dependency
ratio who are you of 15 it still five is
like an adult as five years old the kid
is walking with jugs of water carrying
you know together because employed and
driving two locations of distance it
starts at age five plus in terms of
employment these kids are employed so
when there's your to say youth you have
to understand a lot of contacts are we
saying you a 14 of 15 euro in in in
Haiti is not a youth like the United
States will playing with their toy they
were there working and want to work to
support their families so it's a very
very different conception about youth
program I would rather you advocate to
the powers that be to help the Haitian
government actually put together a
national development core so that you
can absorb it you into real training in
work program that it can network like
the car okay I'm the question can the
shutter that is involved in Haiti can't
it vault no no so that is a problem is
it that's a problem because you are
gasp order to get involved in the
political and economic development of
Haiti but when they are always see they
cannot vote so that's a problem but ok
my next thing is easy i think johnny i
had mentioned that to you once and
having wall with your response i had
asked Johnny the Idaho many Haitians are
in the United States I'm going to talk
about canada and france and that my
question was if we would oppose the tax
and every worked in haitian leave United
States and it works to pay three hundred
dollars a year and that only work to go
into home the end American Development
Bank and that was made for haiti can
this be done that we a nation take a
cast that was I ready to date for the
development of he came to be done I mean
levity in the way of variation
themselves helping your own country by
pinner test that's all
what I mean I think I think the short
answer is that work with advances
government so I don't know how people
text but suddenly I found their
contribution of montevallo the war we're
probably in a scheme that says that this
is going to be part of a trust fund that
will that would be put to use the
development of alien gotta figure out
what development what that is
that is going to be might be a good idea
but something at something that you have
a ready answer for perhaps somebody was
much more familiar with our mental
issues for tax issues would be able to
provide more guidance
so my name is deputy currency and I
psychologist and adrenaline Teachers
College Council represent the
International Association applied
ecology the UN NGO community and I can
step back from hey so I love that i
reward heroism I noticed that the people
were very so good taking real strength
within himself demeanor zillion I'd like
to give the panel respond to the mental
health of the people in this period
besides were health I heard and the
second problem that I'd never get is
about sanitation I only saw four quarter
bodies in the city and this is a major
public position thank you
first on the issue of mental health i
think is extraordinarily important right
now unfortunately all the systems
designed dealer medical health tends to
be on an individual basis when in fact
what some of the needs are huge and need
to be addressed in mass ways I have
known in other circumstances of mental
health professionals taken to the
airwaves to be able to do some kind of
collective counseling to the population
at large this is not a situation where
anyone can get their mental health needs
met and they are tremendous right now
and it's not just of the affected
population it's of all the people trying
to help them it's often times we forget
about the we're trying to help
which to themselves and trying to help
Senate
to look in more than one direction on
the sanitation is absolutely true that
we have to be working now to try to
avoid what the next two or three big
problems we might have but I mean that
they could be like the first wave in
terms of the number of people affected
and so sanitation you know food and
water shelter right there at the top
hello my name is up on Blanco I'm an
architect and planner and someone like
to ask a question to Turgut further in a
comments that were made about the fact
in Haiti port-au-prince and something
between thirty forty percent of the
population and most of the resources
speaking also the exceptionality in this
condition unfortunately this type of
conditions map its atomic program a
Capulet is something that's all too
common back on earth and in severe
consequence of the milkman model and if
you are putting governments and taking
place that have garnered all wells to
the capital last year at UN conference
on habitat someone who's coming behind
the financial sense of organization
around the world with spreading culture
and civilization when in fact someone
else commented that in the country like
India over the last 40 years the only
thing that it seems have grown is the
hundreds of millions of people that are
living in squalor in urban shanty towns
I can save a bit iffy but I can I can
imagine that the quality of life people
in poor Prince must have been busily
before the earthquake my question is is
if you ain't taking steps to make a
development to reinvention of hating
something that presses the knee
absolutely
development so that people are living in
the countryside and also if I gots a
question in this disaster we will
heartily instruction of port-au-prince
so how how far as the disaster extend
into the countryside what is the degree
of a few construction at stake there but
existed before but I'm only asking that
question rhetorically because what I
really want to know is if it's this
reconstruction in Haiti is going to get
attention princessing to rebuild the
country signs and substitution
it's a bit premature because we'll have
to see but I think it's important to
look for example the past year there was
a 5 depending on the sourcing agent
James about five hundred percent of
relevant any cultural sector very
important which wasn't agent sometimes
people and what's right we mentioned
before is something that would ask us to
get the core now of other construction
development effort you see to what
extent those people who want the
countryside will have the social 730 he
will open to stay there and then he
sharing our resources or something I was
like many years ago input apparatus in
his lungs you know think was a new
survey actually was saying was asking
the people you know basically are you
happy now the decision
to France this will work very bored when
you employ terrible conditions
ninety-three percent of the people who
are happier before I'm living there I
mean several years it's hard to believe
but the fact is only six or seven
percent say that they can eventually
conceded one day of that to the
countryside so obviously there was a
reason for that I don't have the answer
was the people were saying so he's very
complicated and finally is a kind of a
personal decision is for you for your
family so that's what I'm saying is he
construction on the button on probation
very complex the Asian has to be at the
core of it and see what it's feasible
it's not same thing for the
reconstruction now is always say about
what you place a transitional com
temporary shelter is a big decision
University for fear that many common
Islam is extremely complex and animals
you take all these ideas and the
consideration eliminations to find
something I just want to add something
and I think that for the audience
as for us or working on this basis to
keep our to devour our tea plants there
there is no shortage of good ideas and
some of the issues that have been raised
are issues that have should be properly
addressed the fact that you have to have
another sort of habitat
livin also includes the idea that
perhaps there should be economic posed
and wouldn't track people had some photo
friends instead of steering them into
the cab elusive so in other words the d
concentration of capital flows and
investment from parents to to other
cities and areas in which to develop at
ten take place will probably leave the
haitians to believe that life there as
well can be better so this will show the
good idea question is that what is the
strategy behind this crucial then going
to be the strategy behind a
reconstruction effort or rebuilding
efforts whatever you may call it what
happens from this point on is crucial
for the international community for the
nations to review they can either look
at the we properly with a pathology that
one
couple of years ago think about some of
its implications so think about the
implications of current disaster and how
you want to address to the needs of the
people of haiti so that it deals with
the number of issues that isn't that if
in fact not come up we're talking about
adultery but I'm sure international
community it comes to the region in the
wake and Apollo for harvest and further
down
states are extremely bored now that if
nothing happens in Haiti that we're poor
by authority of the country then
external migration got to set in and
therefore that's going to be creative of
a huge other problem that is not even
being on the table
first in your students if I'm officer
McNally which took in this out there's
the add to what you're saying one of the
things also that the rural regions like
these infrastructures there's no roads
that facilitate the transport for people
to rural areas Steve all kinds for
example two people would rather just
live in power plants then go through the
burden of you know of going back home in
energies my question is why they take so
long for a to each of rural areas and
even today there's a lot of villages who
have no international NGOs who have no
relief efforts in blackmail I think like
a comparable 80 days without seeing any
effort why isn't the West I'm sorry
I'm sorry
it's definitely a growing boy
why isn't it 18 before pasta too
when you soon
should be in separation the separation
was unfortunately I could say it's
nowhere than to me many reasons for that
I mean people were working there most of
them pass away tomorrow mainly more
important people than directly disappear
so we had to replace his people to be
able to work since we're logistical
issues there in the capital around there
was no information but no access there
but was more functional so you can order
unfortunately shoot and I think you know
is it is no excuse for that what you're
saying is the way it should be age
should be there for day two fact is that
most of the disasters are the people
themselves to the word street were
responded in the first and international
community is often come in after two or
three days before they depending on
against to help so often
to have just one little thing not not to
a question which is really I wanted to
go back into the question on mental
health just look a little bit just see
if you like what I actually mean by
national special development for for
heating is that under question of mental
health who provides mental health right
now affirmations these are the boutique
lead capture the voodoo priests are
foremost the primary mental health
expert for for Asians across the
territory they you know you've got
another problem you've got you know
siblings problem with every single thing
around psychiatry psychology good step
now there's a design connectors a lot of
folks were really worried and we are
were traumatized by this this earthquake
or actually trying to envision how to
you know that's what I'm saying about
who who knows how how do who don't
happen
in the Asian dynamic to deliver services
the first people who have to be trained
in order to deliver services because
that people already go today would be
computed please but yeah the folks who
would you know who have the money to
deliver these services would not go
first hand to those first time people
who are losses a job by the way a limit
right and so what you have to come up
with a program that I promise up pixels
because these folks or what in the
invasion violence is the fundamental of
the you know the senator of their
community and actually the community
leaders but we often bypass those as if
they are not leaders in their community
and they are the ones who people go to
for mental health so you know in a
mental health as because it's part of
life mental health is not we Haitians
have a horror of psychologists and
psychiatrists
just it's just so you just don't go
there right you go to your voodoo
priests and so you know do you too thin
in the language problem is a usual right
so and they're not that many trained
ones the people who are trained in
psychiatry psychology social work or all
Haitian Americans very very few on the
ground and there i mean the few that
they are or not spread into where the
people need them I just wanted to just
to mention something as well as very
important it gonna have some capacity to
respond to this crisis no man has also
seen by the heat the place were they
usually what will happen is they receive
the day after the assessment and they
deploy some support according to the
international community this time we
were also academically I know something
several of the persons were working
instructor that passed away a new path
estoy so this this also was a huge
throwing response and is I think against
of a fine place we start the work
maybelline fun developers they think
that was what it does it's difficult to
this to judge to pass a judgment from
Europe because if you have been twisted
for all of us know the rest of the south
which was hit but you know you can't
explain how much is destroy the roads we
do we try to drive for instance the day
we left to go and let our passport in a
hotel because we have the papers that we
had to leave the country and
connectivity road and then going back it
was blocked everything was blocked
everything was destroyed pies of rebels
people were dead all over the place you
know it's difficult understand ha
porosity the end has been so daddy the
port was destroying the airport had been
hit and so many people were there who
where
he really could have hurt so it's not an
excuse i totally agree with my colleague
from you at Nikita you know Eddie's
never enough but I must tell you that
the circumstances of these particular
crises are really overwhelming and I
don't know the rest hydraulic jack bell
I know it has to be very much destroyed
too but a happy there but the logistic
caused so many problems so I don't know
where they are now because we left we
don't know but I just wanted to tell
that it's very hard to describe and also
the country of everybody was in shock
and also the hell do you know the earth
tu tu tu traveled every day they were
aftershocks that somewhere we you know
strong through people that lost their
loved one people where you know the time
was completely destroyed it's just it's
a problem unity what happened so I'm
sure there were other issues for the a
the lesions of coordination but you know
you have to keep the circumstances
environment as well
it is we're going to charge our city so
maybe we move to the next question he
did see one hi I am Don Carey area first
year and I a suit at ciba and I wanted
to thank out first of all appreciate you
guys understand inside the world Alvin 8
and I just wanted to let you I wanted to
take this opportunity to there as soon
as the Kali a job applied to be
considered for the spring break trip to
eight trying to organize a group of
students for trying to maintain the pack
without borders International Rescue
Committee partners in health and
international organization for migration
the Dominican Republic annotating will
be gone through Santo Domingo if you
have any questions please contact me on
the back door thank you I was gone
native I students see customers who want
to go to really teach the spring to
really follow me situation and make sure
that you tell you something which is in
an instant in time because it's not the
time to learn the country frozen to
speak with studies just not don't know
what you want to do but to follow the
situation very carefully
three and then I tell twitching you to
speak but I think otherwise it
operations my my question is in regards
to the current relief efforts with the
relocation of people to the outskirts of
port-au-prince it's a generally
considered without your and bad idea if
it's a bad idea what I'm alternatives
looking at the current situation and if
it's a good idea or considering the fact
that people are moving I think whether
on a national scale or even individual
basis they were moving away what what
are the plans that are being we or could
we need to get the much needed supplies
& age to these people who walk your own
answers I cannot answer this question
I'm sorry
what exactly they go I know that they
are plans for that I know that is has
come to discuss and immediately baby the
government and the people in the ground
found it is what a solution to the
recorded situation and not in a position
to judge
is there any more question I just want
to add something just in connection with
which she said I section relief centers
/ when you're collecting medical
supplies to be sure to duck male
partners in health is actually helping
us there any less their boats so and
we're going to be setting up our
drop-off centers it asks about so if you
guys want to know it supplies tents
tarps playing it anything that could be
used you can drop them in one we're
going to get on them now very good okay
perhaps we should cocoa Oklahoma City
I just want to thank everybody for
coming are going to say well who has
left I want to do that they started to
that was
your environment complicated were snakes
decided to switch at the last moment at
how the permeability and sensible or has
left that a number of speakers out here
tonight it is not easy getting body
particularly because everybody's healthy
so I want to size the members of the
panel and I hope she's happy to school
an opportunity to get engaged this is a
long haul so thank you for coming